- I spoke to many of these
Muslim, former Muslim,
agnostic Muslim,
moderate Muslim,
whatever you want to
call them, guys saying,
"If we don't take the lead
in breaking this thing open,
"the countries that we have
fled to are going to look like
"the countries we fled from."
(calm theme music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a human rights activist,
a fellow at Stanford
University's Hoover Institute,
a best-selling author
whose new book,
"Prey: Immigration, Islam,
"and the Erosion of Women's
Rights" is out right now.
Ayaan Hirsi Ali, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so much, David.
Thank you for having me on.
- Well, I'm thrilled
to have you on.
We were just discussing
right before we started,
we've done this a couple times.
We'd prefer to do it in person,
but we are left to
the wires of Skype.
So I wanna talk about
the book, obviously,
and that's what we're
mostly gonna do today.
But since I haven't chatted
with you, at least publicly,
in about a year, how's
the year been for you?
How are you doing?
What do you make of the state
of the world, my friend?
- Well, it's
different, isn't it?
And that's obviously
an understatement.
I belong to the
category of people
for whom COVID has
actually been a good thing
in the sense that I can be
very close to my family.
And I have never been
more productive in my life
because we've killed
the commute time, right?
We are not going to the office.
We are not commuting to
the places where I speak.
You know, it would take
me at least three days
to give one single speech,
and now it's Zoom
calls back to back.
That's the nature of our life.
But again, having said that,
I know that there are millions
and millions of people whose
livelihoods are compromised.
That's really sad.
A lot of societies have
cracked their economies.
People are going through all
sorts of mental health issues.
Domestic violence has gone up,
and I couldn't wait
for this thing to end.
I hate COVID.
- Are you shocked, even
though it's been okay for you,
and truth be told, in terms
of my life and my businesses,
it's been okay for me, but
obviously there's all sorts
of horrific stuff happening,
as you're addressing.
Are you shocked,
though, how quickly,
as someone that comes from
a not very free place,
and I think most of my audience
is familiar with your story,
are you shocked how
quickly we in the West
are willing to give up
our rights and freedoms?
- I don't know if the
word to use is shock.
I think the word
that I would use now
it's in the beginning, we
didn't know what was going on.
This could have been
the Spanish flu.
It could have been smallpox,
it could have been
tuberculosis, and again,
because I do come from Africa,
I do come from societies
where large numbers of people
are killed by pandemics,
many of them children
and the young.
Obviously, in the
beginning, I was really
really frightened
like everybody else.
But then the more we find
out about the disease
the more I think our response,
at times, is politicized,
it's overwrought, in some
ways it's exaggerated.
But what really
bothers me the most
is that we can't even
have these conversations.
That if you say, maybe
like my colleague
at the Hoover Institution,
Scott Atlas, who's a scientist,
and if he comes out and he
says, and along with him,
many others who say, "Wait
a second, let's reflect
"on these trade-offs," that
these people are demonized.
And that's what bothers me the
most, because I don't think
that the virus cares if
you're black or white,
rich or poor, religious
or not, they don't care.
The virus doesn't care
about your politics.
And so I think maybe to
use the word shocking
is that I thought
liberal societies
were rational societies
guided by reason.
And right now we're
going through a time
when reason is not the
prevailing characteristic.
And that is unfortunate.
- That's exactly what I wanted
to ask you next, actually,
because you were gracious
enough to give me a quote
on classical
liberalism for my book.
And I think you've been
one of the great defenders
of classical liberalism,
not only intellectually,
but also just by
extension of your life.
But what I'm seeing right now,
and I think this is
what you're hitting on,
it seems to me we're
almost at the end
of Western liberalism.
That sort of the woke-ism and
the giant government stuff
has basically
enveloped liberalism,
and in essence, the good
few remaining liberals
are sort of modern
conservatives.
That actually what
I consider myself,
that I would've never
said that three years ago.
Do you think that's
a fair summary?
- I think that if you go
to a place where you saying
"There is no hope, we're
going to self-destruct,"
then I caution you on that,
and say we have had times
when we were just this
divided and really irrational.
So again, I'm with people
like Steve Pinker on,
actually things haven't
been better for humanity.
If you take that long,
long trajectory from when
we stopped walking on all fours
and started walking upright.
- Yeah, yeah, no.
Well, I know that, of
course things are better.
I've read the book.
I think I've got it back here.
You know, Pinker's book
"Enlightenment Now."
So I know things
actually aren't that bad
although we've got a
certain set of problems,
but I do sense that
liberalism itself
seems to be being
destroyed right now,
that woke-ism has destroyed,
at the academic level,
what you're seeing at
all of the institutions,
that liberalism is in a
particularly tough spot.
- You are absolutely right.
Liberalism, by the way,
I'd say it's probably one of
the youngest of philosophies,
classical liberalism,
and from the time
that the Enlightenment and
classical liberalism emerged,
it has always been under threat.
And there's this
beautiful golden age time
when it triumphed.
But that triumph was, it
was like a back and forth.
You know, we only had the
First and Second World Wars
in the 20th century, right?
In that century,
when things seem,
people seemed to be
attracted to reason.
And I think this is
not going to stop.
Liberalism is once
again, challenged.
Now, obviously, I was
really very much engaged,
as you know, from my background,
with the challenges that
political Islam presents.
The narrative of
political Islam is
liberalism is wrong,
individualism is wrong,
universalism is wrong.
And only the way they see
and the utopia of their goals
is the right way, and that
the way you achieve that
is through violence,
through sacrifice,
through misogyny, and through
all sorts of other affronts
to the idea and
philosophy of liberalism.
Now what's interesting
with the woke ideology
is that it is actually a
byproduct of liberalism,
that it is a disappointment
with the world.
And so if you read that
book, I sent it to everybody
I could send it to,
"Cynical Theories"-
- I have it.
I've had James on, yeah.
- To, I would say, modern day
liberals, Helen Pluckrose,
and James Lindsay.
What they're trying
to show us is that
if you dig deep, and
that's what they've done,
dig deep into the
philosophies that inform
what we now call woke-ism,
cancel culture, critical theory,
critical race theory,
it goes by many names,
but that is an
unintended consequence
of liberalism disappointment
with modernity.
It's a disappointment
with civilization.
It's a yearning for
some kind of utopia.
It does use secular
arguments and underpinnings,
but it does have a
religious quality to it.
I've compared it
with radical Islam.
You know, they want to
shut down free inquiry.
You have those who are
in, and those who are out.
They don't want to have
a conversation with you,
they want to destroy you.
They divide society
into subsets of groups.
They deny objective truth.
They're hostile to science.
Hey, by the way, they say
they're standing up for women,
and gays, and transgender
people, and so on,
but if you look at
what they're saying
they're actually
the most racist,
misogynistic people
in the world.
And so in that sense
I would say here's a new
challenge to liberalism.
It shouldn't surprise us.
If you're a true
classical liberal,
you know that the
challenges, ideological,
philosophical
challenges to liberal
they're commonplace and
they'll stay with us,
because that's what
human nature demands.
And so that's why I don't
want us to go to a place
where we are saying this
is the end of liberalism,
or the end of free society.
I think we should just,
how else, it's like aging.
Liberalism will
forever be challenged.
We just have to be aware
and conscious of that.
And even after radical
Islam is defeated,
woke-ism is defeated,
like national
socialism was defeated,
and all sorts of
other fascistic ideas,
but it's not going to go away.
Something is gonna
come in a new disguise
that will be new to the people
who will be living
through that time.
- Yeah.
You know, it's
interesting when I talk
about sort of the end of
the road for liberalism,
what it means to me
is that now I feel
that I can do much more
work helping to liberalize
or even use some
libertarian principles
with my conservative friends.
That seems like a smart
place to put energy for me,
as opposed to trying to fix
the woke part of this thing.
But I think this is
the challenge for
all of the liberals
at the moment is sort
of which way do you go?
- Which way do you go?
Well, what I'm saying is yes,
you have to find
allies and alliances.
So first of all, we
have to go back to
Americans call
classical liberalism,
they call it conservatism.
The Europeans just
call it liberalism
because that's where
it all emerged.
In any case, I think
the most important thing
for all of us to do right now
is find that center ground.
Talk to people who
are on the center-left
or on the center-right, and
make this attempt, once again,
to marginalize the
fringes and extremists.
And in that sense,
I share your concern
that center's kind
of sagging right now.
And we have to make these
huge efforts to go back there,
go back to sanity.
- Our work is cut out
for us, my friend.
- Our work's cut out for us.
- Our work is cut out for us.
All right, so I wanna talk,
obviously, about the book.
And two things
before we get into
the sort of full part of it,
but on the opener of the book,
on the very first page, you
issue a trigger warning.
And I thought that that
was quite interesting.
It says, "This is a trigger
warning for the entry book.
"Reading it, you
should be triggered."
Now, a lot of my audience is
gonna say, "Wait a minute,
"we don't like trigger
warnings on these things."
Why put a trigger
warning on such a book?
- Well, it's a proclamation
to take on the woke.
And some of the people who
actually don't even know
that they are woke, or
that they've subscribed
to this ideology.
And it's also my way of saying
that if we want to go back
to the center, in other words,
if we want to address some of
the most confounding issues
of our day, that you have
to go back to that table
and in good faith, and
be open and honest.
These are the problems
we are having.
Now, what we've seen, I work,
you know I'm an academic,
I'm in the academic space.
We are constantly bombarded with
you have to be mindful
of, and sensitive to,
students feeling unsafe about
this, and unsafe about that,
and microaggressions.
And so the woke ideology
that used to be fringe
has now become mainstream
to the point where,
at Stanford, you just
get all these emails
that are telling you what
you can and can't do,
what you can and can't say.
There's more political
or philosophical activism
in a way that I have
never seen before.
And so I think you
then start with
I'm actually taking this on.
I want to trigger you.
I think you go to school,
you go to university,
to learn how to think.
When you're admitted
to university, there
is an assumption
that you're a grownup
ready to take on the world
and take on all sorts of
challenges that come your way.
If you're demanding
a safe space,
it was amusing a few years ago.
- (chuckling) Mildly, yeah.
- Mildly.
Now it's just downright creepy.
- Yeah, and it's sort of
taking over everything.
So one of the things that
I really liked that you did
with the book, and this will
get us to some of the topics,
is that I know from
writing a book now,
that organizing a book,
in and of itself is,
is sort of a tough task.
Just figuring out
what goes where,
and that's obviously where
editors help, and everything,
but you basically lay out
the book in four parts.
And I thought we could
just go through each one
and cover a little
bit from each one.
So part one is "The
Unsafe Streets."
Oh, you know what, before
we actually get to that,
another thing that you mention
in the beginning of the book
is that because of COVID,
it did delay publication for
about eight months or so,
so that some of the
numbers actually
may be slightly change,
and some of the behaviors,
which is more interesting,
related to immigration.
Do you want to just
address that at all
just because a lot has
changed in terms of borders
and allowing people
in because of COVID,
not necessarily because of
what the strict European
or unstrict European
regulations were.
- Yeah, so absolutely right.
So the first thing that
you'll notice with the, yeah,
the manuscript, is it was
supposed to be released
in June of last year,
and then it didn't.
(audio cuts out) COVID and we
got all of this other stuff.
- Some stuff was happening.
- I think the first
thing that happened is
the data is moving, or the
process of data gathering.
So when the book goes to press,
we have official statistics
for the countries
and the societies
that actually do collect the
data, and that stuff changes.
So by the time
we're releasing the
book now in February,
things have changed,
people have been
confined to their homes,
and anybody who's an
opponent of airing
this particular
problem will say,
"What are you talking about?
"There are no issues
to talk about."
But why?
"There are no women
on the streets.
"There are not men
"There's no one on the streets.
"It's a huge lockdown,"
stuff like that.
So the first thing is the
challenge of updating that data,
which, by the way, very,
very difficult to gather
to begin with.
And the other one point I
make, there are lots of points,
but the one point I really want,
and that has struck me in
the age of the pandemic
is how governments were
dragging their feet
about this issue, the issues
of Islam, and immigration,
and the integration
or the attempts
to try and develop programs
to assimilate Muslim minorities
into European societies.
And a lot of it was they
had come to the conclusion
we can't do anything about it
because any attempt to
address these issues
would either empower
the far right,
or it would compromise
our liberties.
And then the
pandemic comes along,
and our liberties are
completely compromised,
and we're going along with it.
- Right.
And you also make the
argument in the book
that the more that we don't
talk about those things
that you actually empower
the far right at that point,
because if they go, "Oh,
well if no one in a civil,
"liberal society will deal
"with these honest
challenges that we have,
"well then, congratulations,
"you're just gonna hand
it all to the far right."
- Exactly.
So when we talk
about the pandemic,
the conversations we
have, most of it is
these governments have
screwed it all up.
And then we get into how
things were screwed up.
But this is within the
time-space of just 12 months,
even less than 12 months.
And then you look at how
things were screwed up
when it comes to immigration,
Islam integration,
and the parallels
are fascinating.
- So in an odd sense,
did the last year,
because of the way countries
are dealing with their borders,
did it slow down
some of this stuff
in some of these countries,
because borders were
paid attention to
maybe a little bit
more carefully, just
because of COVID,
not because of
immigration specifically?
- If, in the past, you talked
about borders and immigration,
you would be designated
the status of a xenophobe,
and racist, and you
know the labels.
And so if you raise
the question of
"Hey, Germans, French, UK,
the Netherlands, Canada,
why don't we first
talk about assimilating
The people we already
have within our borders
before we let in new groups,
and then at that point
you're having a
conversation about borders.
And the knee-jerk,
conventional response would be,
"Borders?
"What are you talking about?"
And then (audio
cuts out) follow.
Then along comes COVID,
and everybody's
closing their borders.
Not only that, if I were
to fly from where I am now
to any of those
European countries,
I would be forced to quarantine
for 14 days in my hotel,
or home, or what have you.
And there you have a just
(audio cuts out) violation
of your freedom of movement,
and your freedom of association.
And even in some
discussions about COVID,
your freedom of speech.
Then you say, but if
you're not willing,
we couldn't close borders,
couldn't talk about borders,
but now all we talk
about is, come on.
- So in an odd sense,
that's the silver
lining to this, right?
That's your argument basically,
is that maybe we will be able
to have these conversations
because we realize we can
do some things at borders,
and it doesn't necessarily
make you racist?
- It doesn't make you racist
to say, as elected officials
in government who have been
honored with the responsibility
of allocating the resources
that taxpayers pay,
and the legislative process
to say, and most of us,
you have, I have, all of
us, we've all complied
with what we've been told by
those people that we elected:
stay in your homes,
wear your masks,
keep the six-feet distance,
use the hand sanitizer,
and we're all willing to.
We're very rational about it.
I know that a lot of people
who are irrational about it.
Most people are
rational about it.
If you bring that same
rational thinking,
or at least the good faith,
let's talk about Islam.
Let's talk about immigration.
Let's talk about assimilation.
Let's talk about the impact
that stuff is having on women,
immigrant women, Muslim
women, women in general,
which is the
subject of the book.
I think we would, then you
would say, that's an optimistic.
Then we've learned our
lessons as societies.
The opposite way of doing
that, putting taboos on things,
that will empower the radical
Islamists, Russian trolls.
It'll empower the
extreme right wing.
It will open the door
to authoritarianism.
Let me give you an example.
Look at the government of China.
When they are confronted with
radical Islamic terrorism,
their way of doing things
is interning the entire
Muslim community.
Like that's 10 million
strong in China.
Brainwashing them,
committing genocide,
forcibly sterilizing the women.
We don't want to go there.
- Yeah, literally
happening right now,
what you're talking about.
- Literally happening right now.
That's what happens when you
refuse to talk about things.
Then you open the door
for authoritarianism.
What I'm proposing in the
book is not authoritarianism.
It's like let's develop programs
that introduce to young
men from societies
that are misogynistic,
and homophobic,
and where male aggression
is either encouraged,
or people are just powerless
to do anything about it.
When these young men
come into our societies,
let's socialize them into
freedom, equality, human rights,
let's respect their
dignity, their human rights,
and teach them to
respect that of others.
We have the time to do that.
We can do it.
That's what COVID has shown us.
If we wanted to get the
resources out there,
develop the programs,
and incentivize people
to adopt these values and
change their behaviors,
we can do it.
- Do you think this is
something that Europe
has just failed at in a way
that the United States hasn't,
and maybe the United States
is starting to fail at it
a little bit in terms of
what woke-ism is doing,
meaning that the idea of
multiculturalism in Europe,
which is sort of, "Oh you
can sort of live separately
"in these countries,"
that's very different
than the United States
which was the melting pot,
and is the melting pot still.
- Yeah.
So I think what saves
the United States
from perhaps going
down the path of Europe
is that there is this
concept and lived experience
of the melting pot.
Again, that's challenged now
by not just the Islamists
and all sorts of
external adversaries,
but also by this
homegrown woke-ism,
multicultural ideology.
So in America, I think at
least we have the experience.
We know what it is to
have a melting pot.
And we also reaped
the benefits of that.
I would say the average
American is actually
has quite a positive
attitude toward immigration,
and (audio cuts out) and trying
other cultures, and so on.
In Europe, the
story is different.
And not all European
countries are equal
in their incompetence,
or lack of doing
something about it.
So I think Denmark is
doing a good job now
of acknowledging, okay,
we have a problem.
We're gonna set
these programs up,
and they're having
those debates.
They don't agree,
but think about this: the
Social Democratic Party,
which is the center-left,
is actually in Denmark
implementing the
most far-reaching
assimilation programs in Europe.
Same goes for Austria.
We're seeing the president
of France, Macron,
and you know what,
these parallel societies
these Islamist separatists,
ghettos, we can't have that.
We're gonna have to
do something about it,
and he's willing to
put his political life
on the line for that.
So I'm seeing changes,
I'm seeing differences
in different countries.
Some countries like Sweden,
that's a total basket case.
But in Germany, again,
I think Germans are now
truly frightened by
the emergence of these
far-right groups,
and are actually beginning
to deal with the issue.
So the United Kingdom, again,
I'm seeing changes,
silver linings,
if you want to put it that way,
but still not of the magnitude,
like the situation
hasn't been prioritized
to the extent, say,
that the pandemic was.
- Yeah, it's just
so interesting to me
how you can link this to
woke-ism, and cancel culture,
and everything else, because
when I was in Sweden,
when I was on tour with Jordan
Peterson a couple years ago,
we were supposed to do one show.
It sold out literally
in two minutes.
So we added another show,
and I chatted with people,
actually, during the
show and then after,
saying, "Well,
what's going on here,
"that Jordan's message about
the individual and liberalism.
"Why is it so important?"
And everyone said because
political correctness
had gotten so out of control
that they couldn't
talk about immigration.
They couldn't talk about gender
or any of the other things
that you're talking about here.
And it's like, well, that's
exactly the purpose of the book.
So you lay it out in four
parts that I really like.
So first, you talk about
the unsafe streets.
I think this is the
part when people
see videos from Germany and
France and some other places,
I think this is the part
that's probably the
easiest to identify with.
but can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah, so that
part has to do with,
it became incredibly
difficult to find the data,
to just call these
offices and say,
"Can you just give
me the statistics
"of sexual violence
in your country?"
And then you get
into all sorts of,
"Oh yeah, right.
"I'll call you back tomorrow,"
the dragging of the feet,
and then they give you
studies that tell you nothing.
And sometimes people will say,
"I will share with you the
data, but you know what,
"I don't want my name or
my occupation anywhere.
"I don't want my
fingerprints on it."
And so it was okay,
you know what,
the book has, everything is
in there that I could find.
Then the next thing is how
can I illustrate the problem
without only leaning
on just anecdotes?
And now you go to
the neighborhoods,
and some of the women
will just really take you,
David, to parts of
Sweden, parts of France,
parts of Belgium,
Scandina, anywhere,
and they'll say, "Look around.
"What do you miss?
"What are you not seeing here?"
There's a Swedish, I think
he was a prime minister,
but a senior
politician in Sweden
who was taken some of
these neighborhoods,
and he was asked
the same question,
"What's missing here?"
And he couldn't come
up with an answer.
He looked around and said,
"What the hell is missing here?"
- [Both] Women.
- And why is that?
Because the sexual violence,
and the sexual misconduct,
the harassment, the lewd
cat calls, the obscenities,
that feeling that you're
not safe where you are,
and that the rule of law, so
the people who are actually
supposed to do
something about this,
are not doing anything about it.
Anyway, a victim of sexual
violence is less likely
to go and report.
So in terms of the
different sorts of crime,
it's the least-reported crime.
So a lot of these women
have made up their minds,
and they're behaving
like the women
from the countries of origin
of the men who are responsible
for most of these violent acts.
They're deleting themselves,
erasing themselves
out of some of
these neighborhoods.
And the funny, I mean, I
don't think it's funny,
but I think it's
sad, the sad thing is
that that's not
shrinking, it's expanding.
So there are more
and more spaces
that are becoming women-free.
- And then it also
sort of leaks into
all sorts of other
crimes, right, too?
I mean, it's not just that
so women are basically
staying at home, or staying
afraid, or not going out,
but then it's all the other
crimes that seem to exist.
And when they send
police officers in,
it usually doesn't go that well
- It doesn't go well.
So it's not only women
erasing themselves
out of these spaces,
for instance, Jewish minorities
erasing themselves out.
Gay men and women,
they're adapting.
And when I say adapting,
so that's where integration
is going the wrong way.
And when I lived in the
Netherlands (audio cuts out)
say integration has
to go both ways.
In some of these places, you
see where it's going, right?
And I've heard, and during
the course of doing research
for this book, some of
the officials saying,
"Wait a second, we recognize
that there is a big problem.
"There's nothing we
can do about it."
And there's also
this terrible reality
that you arrest these young
men for sexual misconduct,
they go into prison as rapists,
they come out as terrorists.
The prison system
is just horrific.
And because of that,
I'd rather that
they're raping women
than they're terrorizing.
You know it's like the
craziest trade-offs
you've ever heard.
- Yeah, it's extraordinary.
So part two, which we've
sort of hit on a little bit,
but the European establishment
abrogates responsibility
for women's safety.
Now, we thought that
these liberal societies
were supposed to stand
up for their women,
but we're not seeing this.
I mean, everyone knows
what happened in Germany
a couple years
ago on New Year's.
There's a lot of examples of,
in essence, these countries
throwing women under the bus
in the name of diversity,
or something like that.
- So about 10 years ago.
maybe a little more,
maybe a little less,
I had a discussion with my
friend, Christopher Caldwell
who wrote a lot about
immigration in Europe
and the consequences
intended, unintended,
positive and negative.
And I said to him,
we were talking about
European values.
And I said to him, "You
know, one day the Europeans,
"they probably won't stand
up for freedom of speech.
"They won't stand
up for this value.
up for that value.
"But you know what, when
their women are threatened,
"they'll stand up
for women's rights."
And he just took on that
expression of the wise old man,
and he said, "You're
so optimistic.
"I don't know if they
stand up for anything."
- [Dave] Wow.
- And I'm just, I'm
terrified to say
that he was right
and I was wrong.
- Do you think that was
just naivete on your part?
I mean, you come from a place
where you knew
about these things.
I mean, do you think that was
just sort of an optimist's way
of looking at the world?
That oh, when it really
starts affecting these people,
they will do something,
or do you view human
nature a little differently
after a couple of years?
- I think the first
thing I will say is
because I was surrounded by
European women who are strong,
and who had fought for all
of this stuff, and gained it,
and took it for granted,
I thought they would be
first in line to say,
"This is unacceptable."
So I think that
maybe it blew me,
let me see, I don't know.
It misdirected me into thinking
that there's gonna be,
I know there were all sorts
of confrontations happening,
but when you come
for the little girls,
and you come for the women,
you know society is going
to say that's a red line.
And so I have to confess
that I got that wrong.
I think I also got
wrong the class element.
That wealthy middle-class
women with university degrees,
they're organizing around causes
such as the glass ceiling,
they want to be CEOs, they want
to be on board leaderships,
and stuff like that.
They want to be chancellors
and prime ministers,
and that's what excites them,
and it was a lot of
conversation about childcare
so that you could have 50%
of parliament be female.
And that's what middle-class
women are preoccupied with.
And I didn't realize
that there was that disconnect
between working-class women
and middle-class
wealthier women.
And that's what I'm seeing now.
And maybe that's
why in the beginning
when we were just talking
about immigrant women,
Muslim women, you know, stuff
that they're subjected to,
most people were looking
away because it was
not just foreign, and
they didn't understand it,
but it was also, it
wasn't their problem.
- Right, so that's what's
so fascinating about it
because when it was just
sort of their problem
in their own ghettos,
sort of separate, okay,
that's one thing.
But then when you add this
element of cultural relativism
where you're no longer
allowed to say, I mean,
this is what we've seen.
We see women get
raped on the streets.
We read about grooming gangs,
although you don't
really hear anything
in mainstream media here,
but if you read those things,
and you, well, you're
not allowed to say
that those specific people
who hold those specific views,
that those views are
worse than our views.
Everything's equal.
- Everything is equal.
And they've been saying
that for a very long time.
David, I spoke to
Tino Sanandaji,
who is a Swedish
economist; great guy-
- I had him on a long time ago.
I should have him on again.
- Yeah, he told me,
he was on my podcast.
I interviewed him for the book.
He said to me that there is
an interesting development.
That the people who are
actually coming out now
and talking about these things
are immigrant men and women.
And I asked him, "Do you think
that there is a possibility
"that working class women,
local, native, white women
"could actually ally
with immigrant women
"and immigrant families who've
had enough of the crime,
"who've had enough
of the disruption?"
Remember, they fled
their countries
in search of a better life,
in search of stability
and predictability.
And they're now being
confronted with this mess.
What is the likelihood that
working class families,
men and women, but
especially women,
and immigrant women could
actually form an alliance
and fight this thing.
He's optimistic on that.
He said (audio cuts out)
The other ones at the forefront
of people who are trying
to break open the taboos
are immigrant women.
So immigrant women,
immigrant men, immigrants.
I spoke to Mustafa Panshiri.
I spoke to Hamad Abdullah
Samat in Germany.
I spoke to many of these Muslim,
former Muslim, agnostic
Muslim, moderate Muslim,
whatever you wanna
call them, guys, saying
"If we don't take the lead
in breaking this thing open,
the countries that we have
fled to are going to look like
the countries we fled from.
- Yeah, and then of
course, as you know,
our our friend Maajid Nawaz,
who started Quilliam in the UK,
who hates him?
It's the lefties,
it's the lefties
that hate him, right?
I mean, who's always trying
to cancel him even right now
trying to get his
radio show off LBC,
it's the lefties, because
they're now trying to
frame him a Muslim man
from Egypt, as a racist.
I mean, you know a little
something about this
from your own story.
- He went to Egypt when
he was radicalized,
but I think his heritage,
it probably lies
somewhere in Pakistan.
- [Dave] Ah, okay.
- But it's exactly that.
It's exactly that.
It's the demonization of anybody
who wants to break this open.
And I think that they
are becoming less
and less successful
because you now see the
rise of the far right.
You see the rise of
populist parties.
You see this despair.
Again, I want to
go, as an example,
to the president of
France, who has, you know,
he has to defend his presidency
from Marine Le Pen,
or from Nationale.
(audio cuts out) like that,
and the far left will continue
to try and silence everyone,
but they are not succeeding
because people are suffering.
What the book tries to do
is some of the anecdotes,
that's a description
of real human pain.
And so the more you say, I
told you, some of the victims,
they say, "I'm not far
right; I'm for immigration.
"I worked for left-wing
parties, but I've been raped.
"I've been subjected to this
type of sexual violence."
And I don't want that.
- Right.
Of course.
Well, you don't want
everyone to have to be raped
in essence to wake up, right?
Like, that's what we're
trying to stop here.
- That's what we
are trying to stop.
We're trying to stop the crimes.
And so I think there's,
we are maybe at a moment
in some European countries,
more than others.
I think that's where
Denmark will got to.
It's a smaller population.
Austria, they were talking
about a rape epidemic.
I mean, just think about that.
Before the pandemic they were
talking about a rape epidemic,
and that's what forced the
authorities to do something
about these things.
And so these attempts
at silencing people
by labeling them,
taking away, as you described,
(indistinct), podcasts,
and platforms, and things like
that, it's not gonna work.
It's not going to.
And I'm old enough,
let me tell you this.
I mean, I love the internet.
I'm a proponent of the internet.
I think it's one of the
best things that happened
in my lifetime.
But I'm old enough to know
when there was no internet,
when there were no cell phones,
when very few people
had landlines,
and yet we communicate.
So the tech giants can say,
"I'm gonna take
your platform away."
Good luck with that.
But people will find
ways to communicate.
But the sad story
is, if you say,
"We are going to marginalize
and silence certain views,"
you then have to deal with
the unintended consequences
of censorship, and
censorship never works.
Never worked.
- Yeah, we know they're gonna
find a way to communicate
no matter what.
- (audio cuts out) the
way to communicate.
Yeah, remember Martin Luther?
- Right.
They're gonna figure it out
If they have to nail a
piece of paper on a door,
they're gonna figure it out.
- They're gonna
figure it out, yeah.
- You've mentioned
Germany a couple times.
This is sort of a little bit,
part three is "Clashing
Civilizations Revisited."
Germany's sort of a unique
case because they obviously
are only 70 years off,
or no, about 90 years now
off the Holocaust.
They have a very
strange situation
where there's a lot of
guilt, in some cases
very unearned guilt
for young people
that just happened
to grow up German.
But now because of the
immigration situation,
there does seem to be a
new right growing there,
a new far right, let's say.
What could you tell us about
what's going on in Germany?
- Well, a number of things
are going on in Germany,
and here's like the
great paradox of our day,
because, like you said, just
about 90 or so years ago
they were trying to
occupy the rest of Europe.
They were obviously,
and they have a
lot to atone for.
But carrying out the
Holocaust, and trying to gas
and eliminate different
types of minorities.
And the paradox today
is that they are leading
in this European
unification project.
So on the one hand, that project
is just so time-consuming
resource-consuming,
and they want to get the
buy-in of all of these
other European countries
and their populations.
But on the other hand,
they have to atone
for all of that stuff
that they did in the past.
And their past is way more
raw and way more recent
than, let's say, the
other European countries.
And so they want to demonstrate
that they are, in fact,
no longer racist, that
they have given up
on their national identity.
For a lot of people, Germany
just means occupation,
invasion, Holocaust,
crime, crime, crime
against human beings.
So they're atoning for that.
And so they want to
illustrate, here, look,
we were welcoming immigrants.
We are different.
You know, they want to show
that they have changed.
David, you can't fix
the problems of today
by trying to fix what you
didn't do in the past.
And that's black spots
on the German past
will always be there
just like in America.
You know, we did engage in
slavery and segregation,
and we denied fellow human
beings their civil rights.
That will never go away.
That'll be part of our history.
The Holocaust will be
part of Germany's history.
But you can't fix that by saying
we're going to throw
women to the wolves now.
- Do you think Merkel,
it's too late for her?
Because she, at first, was
one of the big proponents
of opening borders and let as
many people in as possible,
and give, I mean, there
was a huge problem
a couple of years ago
where they were giving
so many social services to
all of these new immigrants
that that new immigrants, or
people that had been there
for 10 years started
getting upset.
But now she's kind of
backtracked on that,
and has gone a little
more hard line.
But do you think it's
kind of too late?
- Well, she's leaving anyway.
There'll be someone else.
And then they'll have to
choose a party leader,
and then we'll have elections,
and I hope they'll end up
with figures from the center,
whether it's center-left
or center-right.
I think early on
in her leadership,
Angela Merkel was a fresh
voice, a fresh face.
But then as time went on,
you get that whole thing
about power corrupts.
And I don't think
she's a corrupt person,
I just think maybe power
makes people tone deaf.
And she was tone deaf
to the failure of the
integration process.
And so flinging the doors open
when the integration process
had failed so miserably,
I think that was a
failure of leadership.
Now that is a very harsh
judgment coming from me.
And I don't know what I would
have done in her position.
But when I spoke to some of
the German senior people there
they were saying that it
was done, that's 2015,
okay, the willkommen culture,
let's just open the doors,
let's let everyone in.
They said there was no thought.
It was thoughtless.
And that didn't only
cause problems in Germany,
it caused problems
all across Europe.
And it also causes
problems to that EU project
that they were spending so
much time and energy on.
And that's how the people talk
that I've spoken to in Germany.
- Yeah, I mean, in many
ways, at least partly,
that was what fueled Brexit.
I mean it was mostly
an economic thing,
but it obviously had
to do with borders
and immigration, as well.
- Absolutely.
And you know, we talk
about buy-in, right.
Buy-in, trying to persuade
leaders of different countries
that have different cultures
and different languages,
and trying to persuade
their populations
to subscribe to the
European project.
And then you do
something like this.
You know, you just say,
"Okay, I don't really care."
That's the unintended
message, maybe,
that you are
conveying, and yeah,
I would say a lot had to do
with, when it comes to Brexit,
a lot had to do with that
tone-deaf attitude to Islam,
immigration, the
clash of values.
Same with countries like
Hungary, Europe, sorry, Poland,
some of these Eastern European
countries that have taken
on a harder line
toward immigration.
I think a lot of it has
to do with them feeling
that the leadership of the
core of the European project
are just not listening to them.
They're full of-
- So do you, yeah, do you
think that places like Poland
and Hungary are just
much better suited,
at this point, to
survive all of this?
Because of that?
- I think it depends on
whether they feel that
they're being listened to,
and that they're not
being condescended to.
It's the same experience
we had here in America
where a lot of people
voted for Donald Trump
because they felt that they
were being condescended to,
that the establishment
had contempt for them,
and only contempt.
And there are a lot
of people in Europe,
some small countries,
some bigger countries,
who are saying you know,
"These people in Brussels,
"they don't see us as
fellow human beings.
"They call us parasites
in xenophobia.
"They don't see our problems.
"They're full of
contempt for us."
And that obviously leads,
if you're a democracy,
at the end of the day,
you're going to have to rely
on the by-in, the votes,
you know, electoral victory.
Then you'd better
listen to the people
that you want to give you power.
- So that's actually a
perfect segue to part four,
which is "Solutions
Fake and Real."
So what are some of
the fake solutions,
'cause I feel like those are
the ones that'll probably
end up being used,
at least for a while.
- One fake solution is that
this web, very complex web
of legislation, rules, agencies,
that governs immigration
in Europe, that that is to
be maintained going forward.
That's a fixed solution.
It has failed.
The asylum and refugee system,
the immigration system that
these countries have in place,
are too complex, full
of too many loopholes,
too many special interests.
And when I talk about
special interests,
I'm not only talking about the
legitimate special interests
that lobby these governments.
I'm also talking about
people smugglers,
and human traffickers.
So there're just too
many, it's too complex.
And so we have to go and review
and revisit that that's a fake.
So to carry on saying why
don't we make a distinction
between those
qualify for asylum,
and those who don't
I think that is totally,
that that has failed.
People who keep pushing
that are actually
really pushing their
special interests.
I think the second fake
approach would be to say,
you take a bunch of
people in your country,
and I'll take a bunch
of people, and so on.
The reason why that is
fake is how many people
could a country like Denmark
take, or even Germany,
even the bigger countries?
That would be like
a drop in the ocean
when it comes to the displaced
peoples in the world.
In fact, I was reading
a UN report yesterday
that said 70% of the
people who end up
on the shores of
Europe seeking asylum
will not be granted asylum.
They don't all.
Seventy percent.
And you know what, the
pandemic is gonna cause
food shortages.
Because of food shortages
there'll be more conflict.
Because of conflict, there'll
be more displaced people.
So the trend of the
millions of people
who are trying to
get into Europe,
that's not going to go down.
That's only going
to go up, up, up.
So what, then, would
be the real solution,
and that would be to have
a serious conversation
about push and pull factors.
And you look at
the push factors,
and the only way to really
deal seriously with that
is through a collaboration
of these various countries.
And that would have to be
let's break down the silos
between the foreign
affairs departments,
the defense departments, the
development aid departments,
the economic affairs department.
You break all that down and
you have to then figure out
a more sort of, I would
say, I'm getting tired now,
but it's like a big picture
approach sort of in ways
equal to what we're doing
about the pandemic now.
We're forcing a lot of
countries to collaborate
on compromising their economies,
or sacrificing the freedoms
of their populations to say
let's get this
thing under control.
And I think that kind of
approach would be appropriate
for the immigration.
And it's not immigration.
Immigration is the
wrong word to use here
for this mass
movement of people.
- So one more for you, which I
think will sum up everything.
Are you hopeful?
Are you hopeful for the
world at the moment?
I think a lot of people
are very fearful,
and I've been trying
on my show every day
to show them that you can't
just be dominated by fear.
You have to be
dominated by hope.
Your life story is
a story of hope.
Are you hopeful
that we can solve,
not only what we're
talking about here,
but just sort of all
of the giant issues
that seem to be
confronting us right now?
- And you know, when
you say giants, you know
think back about it.
It's not even so
giant right now.
Remember when America
was about to break up
because there were
people who had slaves,
and people who wanted
to go to war to end it.
That was a giant issue.
The slave trade all
across the world back then
was one of the most
profitable enterprises,
and we were able to end it.
We fought two world wars,
and human beings
were able to recover.
There are all sorts
of places in the world
where all sorts of conflicts
are going on at the moment.
And people are able to
get out of it, recover,
and leave something better
for the next generation.
So I am hopeful now that
we're really in a place
where science,
technology, money.
We have so much money.
I think if we put all
of those resources
we have the largest
number of educated people.
When I say educated,
I mean literate people
who can read and write.
My grandmother and my mother
could not read or write.
So in the modern world, we
have just so much to work with
to make things better
But do we want to do it?
It's the political will.
And that we, people
like you and me,
we just have to
keep harping on it.
- I have nothing
better to do, do you?
- No, no.
So between fighting
radical Islam and woke-ism.
- All right, we got our work
cut out for us, I guess.
(audio cuts out)
Well, the book is "Prey."
The link is right down below,
and it's just great
to see you, as always,
and hopefully in person
next time, my friend.
- In person next time.
Thank you so much again
for everything that you do.
- Thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlists.
They're all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.